All right, let's add a step now.
I provided some fixed server log data.
What we are doing here is counting the
number of hits to the main web page for
each day in the logs.
You can use the mapper or reducer
files I provided or write your own.
Upload the extracted data, the mapper,
and reducer files to your S3 bucket.
The mapper and reducer are written
in Python for Hadoop streaming.
So, for the step 2 streaming program.
So here is where you link to your
mapper and reducer programs.
Click the folder icons to select
the files on your S3 bucket.
And same thing for the input,
and find the output.
And give this a name,
something like Hits.
And run it, just hit Add.
Down here you can see the step running.
You can also view the logs to see
what's happening on the cluster and
you can also see the jobs running
to make sure they're not failing.
If they do fail you can look at the job
logs to help to bug your MapReduce code.
All right, now that is done running,
you should see the output
data on your S3 bucket.
The process is similar for
high events spark jobs.
You put your analysis code
input data on this three,
then link to them when adding the step.
And don't forget to
terminate the cluster.
If you leave it running,
it can cost you quite a bit.